do I have to tell dinner guests if our
meal contains genetically modified food
oh I see what you did there big Agra
executive who prefers to remain
anonymous the old how do i creatively
upset hippies who oppose genetically
modified foods bit a decent human being
say one who wouldn't do a small family
farmer for trying to use his company's
patented seeds more than one seasoning
of Rome would simply consult with guests
ahead of money even if they aren't
fanatical foodies Gary Comstock an
ethicist at North Carolina State
University told me that by virtue of
this being a host guests relationship
you want to be considerate of their
interests you tell a vegan if their high
tech cocktail was clarified with
crustacean derived kindest and right
right but let's say you forgot to ask
ahead of time wink wink and end up
buying and serving genetically modified
food to your hippie guests at the end of
dinner jump up on the table
and announce the rules in a grand style
then super scoundrels for inadvertently
eating your company's patented food I'm
mr. know-it-all
which means I already know whether or
not you are interested in clicking on
the subscribe button you are